we're asked to simplify 5x squared plus
8x minus 3 plus 2x squared minus 7x plus
13x so really all we have to do is we
have to combine like terms terms that
have X raised to the same power and the
first thing we can do we could actually
get rid of this parenthesis right here
because we have this whole expression
and then we're adding it to this whole
expression the parenthesis really don't
change our order of operations here so
just let me just rewrite it once without
the parentheses so we have we have 5x
squared my plus 8x plus 8x minus 3 plus
2x squared if this was a minus then we'd
have to distribute the negative sign but
it's not so plus 2x squared minus 7x
plus 13x now let's just look at the
different terms that have different
degrees of X let's go start with the x
squared terms so you have a 5x squared
term here and you have a 2x squared term
right there so 5 of something plus 2 of
that same something is going to be 7 of
that something so that's going to be 7x
squared and then let's look at the X
terms here so we have an 8x right there
we have a minus 7x and then we have a
plus 13 X so if you have 8 of something
minus 7 of something you're just gonna
have 1 of that something and then if you
add 14 of that something more you're
going to 15 so this is going to be plus
15 X 8x minus 7x I'm sorry you're going
to 14x 8 minus 7 is 1 plus 13 is 14 plus
14x that's these three terms 8x minus 7x
plus 13 X and then finally you have a
negative 3 or minus 3 depending on how
you want to view it and that's the only
constant term you could imagine it's you
could say it's x times X to the 0 but
this it's a constant term it's not being
multiplied by X and that's the only one
there so minus 3 and we've simplified it
as far as we can go we are done